If you've watched any of the other
interviews I've done here at Udacity
you'll notice that I'm in
the other chair today,
and that's because we're talking about
a topic that is very important to me.
My dissertation research was on using
an intelligent tutoring system in
an exploratory learning environment
to teach students meta-cognition.
And meta-cognition is really the thing
I'm ultimately most interested in, so
I'll be talking about that today.
Also, Jason has again agreed to give me
my questions for this little interview.
>> All right David, let's get started.
Why do you have so
much interest in meta-cognition?
>> So the main reason I have a lot
of interest in meta-cognition
is that there's actually research,
that you've probably covered so
far in this lesson,
that shows that meta-cognition
is the chief determinant in
students success going forward.
That if there's on thing we can
teach them, that will really
ensure that they're successful in later
academic career, it's meta-cognition.
It's thinking about how do I learn,
what are the best processes for me?
How do I monitor that when I'm trying
to learn something if I'm struggling.
Instead of just continuing
to just struggle and
assume that there's something wrong
with me if I can't learn this material.
How can I actually reflect on this,
and say what is it about this that I'm
struggling with, and
how can I adjust for that?
So to really treat the learning
process as a first class object.
Really think about that as a part of the
learning, that the process is something
that I can control,
that I get to drive my own learning.
And this is really important because,
it's kind of that old principle,
if you teach a man to fish,
he'll eat for a lifetime.
If you teach a person to learn,
they'll learn for a lifetime.
Many times in education we're focused
on teaching students some material, and
the material is very important and
I would never insult that.
But if you teach a student
to learn in general,
that's really going to help
them later in their life, and
that's the main reason I'm most
interested in meta-cognition.
I think that philosophically, it's what
really determines students success, and
there's also empirical
evidence that says that.
A student's mindset towards learning
is what will determine whether or
not they're successful at new
things that they come across.
>> Oh wow.
That's pretty powerful.
>> Yeah.
>> What
are some of the main challenges in
teaching students about meta-cognition?
>> So the main challenge is
that meta-cognition by its very
definition is inside the head.
It's I'm thinking about my own thinking.
So the thinking is inside the head, but
at least when I'm thinking about like
the cameras that are in front of me,
I can think about how they work.
I can reason about them physically.
I can reach out.
I can adjust them.
I can manipulate them.
When I'm thinking about thinking, I'm
thinking about something that's inside
my head as well, and so
if I'm teaching somebody algebra,
I can look at the output
of what they're doing.
But with meta-cognition,
I'm not looking explicitly on
the output of their meta-cognition.
I'm looking at the output of
the thought that was reasoned over, so
there's a couple layers of separation
away, we're talking so much about
thinking about thinking, it's a little
bit hard to even have the conversation.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's part of the reason why it's so
difficult, is that,
what are we thinking about and when.
So that's part of the difficulty.
But because we're not operating
on something that we can see,
we're kind of feeling around in
the dark, and we're trying to figure out
what a person is really thinking
underneath the hood, so to speak.
Can I look at the things that you're
actually outputting, or saying, or
writing, and
use that to infer something about
the meta-cognition that went into it,
and it's very difficult.
And it's difficult for human tutors,
for AI tutors it's even more difficult,
because they don't have the benefit
of all the information that we have.
They don't have the nat's of the human
empathy that I think a lot of teaching
meta-cognition to another person is
that you're a person, I'm a person.
To a certain extent,
I can put myself inside your mind, and
I can kind of re-simulate that.
Computers have no natural
ability to do that.
>> Right.
>> So even just building in
human empathy, or human thought,
or human, approaches to problems,
is part of being able to teach them
to do, to teach meta-cognition.
So yeah, the main reason it's difficult
is what we're operating on is invisible,
and it's not easy to manipulate
something you can't see.
>> For sure.
>> Yeah.
>> How can technology foster
meta-cognitive development?
>> So even the main thing that we first
have to wrestle with is exactly the same
issue that I mentioned before.
The main challenge to facilitating
meta-cognitive development
is making the invisible visible.
>> Right
>> Taking what's invisible
inside the brain and putting it out
on the page, putting it in software,
somewhere like that.
And so the way we can do that, is by
structuring the environment in which
this development takes place, such that
students have to make that explicit.
So one way we can do it is by
asking them to do what we call
think-aloud protocol, which is where
they go through an activity and
just think aloud about it.
It's not the best approach because
research has shown that, when I ask you,
while you're doing whatever you're about
to do, tell me what you're thinking?
It actually changes the way you think,
and so I don't get at the root of what
you would really think if you
weren't actively reflecting on it.
But at the same time it gives you
a learning experience of making your
own thought process explicit,
which is very valuable that even
sometimes just making students
aware of what they're thinking.
Even if we're not entirely sure what
they're actually thinking, just forcing
them to reflect on it can be the most
valuable learning experience of all.
But in my dissertation research,
what I ended up doing was taking
a certain part of the activity
that students were completing and
asking them to output that to the page.
So it was constructing theories to
explain natural phenomenon, and
part of that is why do I
believe what I believe.
That's part of meta-cognition,
is reflecting on the internal
reasons that underly my beliefs.
And so we took that and basically said,
take whatever it is that makes you
believe what you're currently believing,
and put it on the page.
Code it in a certain way as a kind
of classification system of saying
this is an example of
this kind of belief,
this is an example of this kind
of belief, and put it out there.
So we're making explicit, something
about the meta-cognitive process.
It's not always easy.
Actually, it's never easy, but
it's not always impossible, but for
certain domains, we can do some
things where students are asked
to make their meta-cognitive
process explicit.
And in fact, it's something that we do,
I think, really strongly in this class,
or at least we try to,
which is take the way you think about
the course material and externalize it.
Externalize it into context
to your own problems.
Externalize it in the context of the
solution that you'd like to develop, and
share that with your classmates.
And in that way, you're sharing a little
bit about how you approach the problem,
and how you're thinking about a problem
with others to get feedback on your
meta-cognition a little
bit more explicitly.
Again, not easy, and I don't think I
could even begin to imagine right now
how I might design an AI agent to be
a TA, or an instructor for this class.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But maybe several years from now,
based on a project that someone in this
class starts to develop, we might start
to see a meta-cognitive agent that's
more than just a tutor, or guide.
It's actually kind of a partner, or
a mentor in an environment like this.
It can mimic some of the things that it
wants you to learn to do, which I think
is really the best approach for teaching
meta-cognition, is to demonstrate it.
To show, this is how I would think
about this problem that you might want
to think about this way, so.
>> That's fascinating.
>> Thank you again, Jason, for
interviewing me on another topic.
>> Of course, dude.
>> And thank y'all.